women are more picky in their mate
choices than men especially sexually
that that's the case in every culture
it's and it's not surprising because
women have more at stake sexually than
men do you know per episode because men
don't get pregnant obviously
and so that female pickiness is that
that's that's the case that that's
definitely true whether it's worse now
or not i doubt if it is
um i would say to young men who are
irritated at women
is if you're irritated at women you know
as a class of creature there's something
wrong with you because they're right
you're wrong
they're right
to not pick you if they're not picking
you it's because they're right
wow now that might get i know that's a
terrible thing to say and i know
perfectly well
it wasn't like i was particularly
successful with girls when i was young
you know so i know what that rejection
is like i know what that fear is like i
don't know it as well as some men know
it because i wasn't rejected outright
so but but what you have to understand
is that what do you expect from women
if you got pregnant because you had sex
you'd be pretty damn choosy too so you
know clue in a bit and then well don't
they find you attractive well maybe
you're not
like have you paid attention to how you
dress do you have a plan
are you as educated as you could be
you know
are you liar
are you a rabid pornography user because
maybe that's undermining your motivation
to
seek out a woman and grow yourself up
it's like if you're rejected constantly
and you're out there really trying you
know because that's another thing to ask
yourself is well how many women have you
actually asked out and are you so sure
that you're not picking women who will
certainly reject you because you're
trying to bat out of your league because
you might be
so and i i'm speaking about this as a
clinician too because i had plenty of
men in my practice who were you know
radically unsuccessful with women i had
one man in particular he was so afraid
of women he couldn't even well he
couldn't use the phone he was too afraid
of everyone to use the phone
and he had been bullied like mad and
and you know he had his problems
so i know what this is like but
pornography is a big problem
it's a big problem it's it's a real
curse that pornography
um in my opinion
because it's an easy out
and so we don't know
we don't know what the consequences of
that are we starting to understand some
of them
but
if you were if you were better
you'd be more successful with women
so you have to you have to have that in
your mind and they're not you cannot be
angry at women
it's stupid
women
it's like
that's
it's like women being angry at men
it's it's a sign of psychological
trouble that
so you feel as though dr peterson is
that you know for the for the men who
are complaining about the
the standards of women today and being
elevated that it's it's it's not so much
a a focus of
pointing the finger at them not choosing
them but more so looking in the mirror
and asking themselves what can they do
to improve themselves to be so desirable
instead of focusing simply in on the
inability of you know be a little
stronger
be a little stronger dress a little
better speak a little more clearly aim a
little higher
like
and practice that you know and that'll
work now you know i know
that that's more difficult for some
people than others because some people
bear incredibly difficult developmental
burdens you know and i'm not saying that
this is easy but i'm saying that
it's a useful reaction like what else
are you gonna do
what else are you gonna do complain
about women
you know i've seen that in men i went
out with a group of men who were having
trouble with their wives and they'd gone
off to this like couple's retreat
and it was mostly rubbish although they
were trying a bit to get their lives
together and i spent a whole day with
them there were three of them and one of
them was a guy that i'd known for quite
a while and every single word he said
was a lie
and so and all these three did the whole
day was complain about their wives and i
thought what the hell is wrong with you
guys like you picked them
they're they're these women you picked
you know and maybe they have their flaws
but they're your wives
and that's how you talk about them and
you think
they're the problem you're so dumb that
you don't even know
that you shouldn't bad mouth your wife
just because she's your wife like when
tammy and i got married we had a
discussion about that it's like
she has her flaws and i have my flaws
but i'm her husband and she's my wife
and there's a certain respect that goes
along with that category
if you have any sense
and so that's an extension of the same
thing
you know it's best to look to yourself
now that now and then you can you know
things have gone rotten in society and
you have to
to bear your responsibility you have to
address that at a social level and a
communal level but fundamentally it's
like
and you do so so much less harm if you
look to yourself first as the problem
beth and believe me you're plenty of
problem for you that's you're all the
problem you need for you that's for sure
[Music]
you